مشاهدينا بفيديو وصف بانه ياسر القلوب
لمكه المكرمه والمسجد الحرام من الفضاء
نشرته ريان برناوي رائده الفضاء السعودي
عبر حسابها في تويتر ارفقت المقطع المصور
بتعليق بعد ما خلصت تجاربي لليوم صدف
مرورنا فوق مكه المكرمه نور على نور كانت
برناوي اول رائده فضاء عربيه قد شاركت
ايضا صورتها على حسابها في تويتر وهي
ترتدي اقراط جدتها في الفضاء في اشاره الى
علاقتها القويه بها اذ كتبت حلقت بحلق
جدتي للفضاء لتحصد الصوره العديد من
الاعجاب ممتنين او متمنين لها العوده
سالمه من مهمتها التي تستمر عشره ايام في
محطه الفضاء الدوليه توصلين بالسلامه
تقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات